wait wait wait a minute hold it right
there let me ask you a question what do
you see here if you're thinking AEI
you're right this is the headquarters of
the American Enterprise Institute but at
heart
AEI is more than just a place I II I is
an idea
it's an idea that champions individual
liberty advances American leadership
lifts people to their highest and pulls
them up in their lowest it's the idea
that competitive free enterprise is what
makes this all possible while the
expressions have changed and many
different faces have made their mark the
idea has been the same since our
founding is a nonprofit nonpartisan
research institution located in
Washington DC you see this idea will
always be needed I'm confident that a II
I will carry on this vital work another
four decades and Beyond join us in
continuing a legacy that is reaffirmed
every day ladies and gentlemen please
welcome a EEI president Arthur Sze
Brooks
good evening ladies and gentlemen please
take your seats good evening ladies and
gentlemen I'm Arthur Brooks president of
the American Enterprise Institute
welcome to the 2018 annual dinner and
Irving Kristol award we're here tonight
with old friends and new friends and
good food in this beautiful setting to
celebrate here at the National Building
Museum a community that we have built
together
AEI is a community of 250 scholars and
staff and 1,600 supporters as many of
you know we were founded in 1938 80
years ago this year this is our 40th
annual dinner amazing some of you have
been to most of them my first AEI annual
dinner was in 2007 I was a professor at
Syracuse University and I was invited as
a visiting scholar at AEI to attend this
wonderful event and my wife Esther and I
we came down from Syracuse like country
mice and we looked at this crowd and we
said these are people I only ever see on
TV and and we were watching the speaker
with binoculars and which gives you an
idea what table I got and and Esther
turned to me and she said can you
imagine hosting this dinner and I said
no chance America is such a great
country within a year I was president of
the American Enterprise Institute you
never know what life has in store for
you this is my 10th year as host of this
event and it's also my last as many of
you know I announced a few months ago
that this is the last year of my
presidency of AEI over the past 10 years
I've given over a thousand public
speeches and service of our mission
traveling all over this great country
talking about dignity and human
potential and gathering support for the
magnificent work of AEI scholars
who are just like you dedicated the
principles of limited government in a
free society and the belief that
America's values are a gift to the world
what a privilege has been when I first
began this job 10 years ago I will be
honest I was extremely nervous about
speaking in public I hadn't done it that
much it was something I needed to get
better at and somebody gave me a piece
of advice they told me to read a book
not a lofty piece of literature that our
scholars produce but rather a book on
self-improvement it's a famous book by
Dale Carnegie how to win friends and
influence people and in that book Dale
Carnegie brilliantly travels all over
the United States and and and asks the
most successful people the secrets to
their success
now in that book when he's talking to a
great magician of the time in the 1920s
Howard Thurston he asks what is the
secret to your performance you're the
greatest performer of your generation
and Howard Thurston the magician he said
simple gratitude he said every night
before I go out on stage I recite this
little meditation
I am grateful because these people came
to see me they make it possible for me
to make my living in a very agreeable
way I'm going to give them the very best
I possibly can and then right before he
stepped on the stage he said I love my
audience I love my audience they gave me
a lot of help early on in this in this
job because gratitude and practice
really are the secret to good
performance but I was thinking about
that earlier today and occurred to me
that as I step on stage tonight and I
gave that same little meditation of
gratitude and love it's not just to calm
my nerves it's really a sincere
expression of the gratitude and I love
and love that I feel for the people in
this room and I want to take just a
couple of minutes and tell you why I
have so much gratitude toward you to
begin with here tonight among this group
are my true intellectual heroes
and some of my closest friends as a
graduate student many years ago I
remember reading the works of great AEI
scholars leon kass and nick ever stat
and and Michael Novak and and I thought
to myself I will never meet these people
but they they helped me to understand
that my views about individual liberty
and American strength they're not weird
and I can be an intelligent cultured
sophisticated person and maybe even a
public or professional intellectual and
hold these views I'm so grateful for
that nothing gives me greater
satisfaction than to support the work of
the scholars and staff of AEI and and in
particular I want to mention one I want
to mention the scholar that has had more
influence on my thinking than any other
single individual and that's Charles
Marie
charles murray retired from full-time
service at AEI this year you wouldn't
know it based on his productivity you
can't tell when Charles Marie's retired
charles murray is somebody that I
started reading many many years ago and
when I read his work I thought if I
could use data and social science like
that to try to express things that are
going on in human life then I would be
successful and when I finally came to a
II I and I can't I was president of AEI
in a call of Charles and I said Charles
can we have lunch and he said you're the
president of AEI and we got together and
I realized that he's not just a great
scholar he's a great friend he was going
to be and indeed he has become a role
model for me in so many ways what a gift
it's been to be a small part of his
extraordinary career my life has also
been immeasurably enriched by my
friendships with people in this room
people like totally friedman and dan dan
yellow the court call chairman of AEI is
extraordinary board and so many other
members of this community these people
have not only supported me as I've been
the head of this organization they've
patiently taught me about leadership if
things have gone well at AEI it's
because of them the second source of my
gratitude was probably even more obvious
than that as you know as you should know
this institution doesn't just run on
good feelings although we have them we
spend about fifty million dollars a year
to build our idea agenda and communicate
it to millions of people every year
around the world we actually have the
most inefficient business model in
America we're in the business of losing
50 million dollars a year in
intellectual property
and you make that possible it's
incredible we combine your financial
resources with the intellectual
resources of our scholars and staff to
produce the expression of our shared
values on behalf of people at the
periphery of society but here here's the
greatest source of my gratitude as I
finish tonight at a tie we have a
subversive mission that you support from
the earliest days ie eyes motto was that
a competition of ideas is fundamental to
a free society think about that a
competition of ideas not agreement on
one thing but to compete freely why
because competition brings excellence
monopoly brings stagnation and it brings
meteor Kirti that's true in the economy
and it's true in electoral politics and
it's true in ideas to get true
excellence we need to disagree and
disagree freely with civility and
respect and even love for each other
that's what we stand for no party line
[Applause]
we have a crisis in this country today
of too many people in public life not
dedicated enough to the competition of
ideas but rather too many people intent
on shutting down that competition with
insults and intimidation and even
contempt
that's leads to mediocrity but it also
is morally disordered every single
person in this room loves someone with
whom they disagree politically when in
our culture of contempt when strangers
on your side politically urge you to say
that your loved ones are stupid and evil
we have a major problem I am most
grateful to be a member of a community
that rejects the culture of contempt we
are a countercultural
and that's fine we simply do our work
and we remember our mission principles
let me remind you of these mission
principles that we are brothers and
sisters human dignity is radically equal
for all of us in all circumstances in
all stages of life every place in the
world
[Applause]
that progress progress were progressives
progress is always possible by
unleashing the greatest source of energy
in history which is human potential and
it is the American free enterprise
system that has pulled billions of our
brothers and sisters out of poverty in
our lifetimes that is the most potent
system ever discovered to instantiate
the human potential
[Applause]
and it's America's international
leadership economic cultural diplomatic
and military that has set people free
around the world to live up to their
highest potential and with our hard work
and with our prayers America will always
do so
[Applause]
let me sum up what we're all about at
AEI we want America to live up to its
promise as a country of ambitious
riffraff pursuing happiness building
something good and meaningful earning
our success sharing our values and
serving each other these are the
principles that are written in the
hearts of the people in this room and
instantiated every day by the scholars
and staff and supporters and trustees
and Friends of the American Enterprise
Institute what fills me with gratitude
the most is having been given the gift
of leading not this organization but
indeed this movement for the past 10
years god bless you and thank you so
very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you and now it's on to our program
and a wonderful program it's going to be
the intellectual program comes first
then supper and then the serious
business of drinking and exchanging
business cards tonight we're honored as
always at this event at a bestow ayyyy
eyes annual award the irving kristol
award named in memory of our beloved
friend and colleague the late urban
crystal before we introduce this year's
winner I want to turn the mic over to
Bill Kristol friend is so many of us for
so many years in son of irving kristol
and editor-at-large of the Weekly
Standard he's going to spoke for a
moment about his father and his legacy
ladies and gentlemen bill kristol
[Applause]
[Applause]
a good evening it's an honor to join
Arthur and welcoming you to this annual
dinner and graduating Boris Johnson on
the I think it's the 15th Irving Kristol
award
it's a distinguished group that Boris
joins before that actually there were
about a quarter century of Francis Boyer
Awards so it passed is also a very
distinguished group if you look it up
back go back to 1977
I remember when Chris DeMuth in 2003
told my father that the AI board had
voted to change the annual award and
lecture from the Francis Boyer lecture
to the Irving Kristol lecture he was my
father was not much moved by these kinds
of honors honestly but but did that one
meant something so ma I meant so much to
him and I remember later on talking to
him and saying but don't you feel a
little guilty a little bad about Francis
Boyer
yeah and my father said no really he had
a good run you know I think the crystal
award is that a good run and hopefully
he has a few more years in it but it's a
dog-eat-dog world out there you know
creative destruction all that stuff that
people in AI are in favor of so anyway
it's it has been a wonderful group I
mean preceding bars people like charles
murray whom arthur mentioned and Rabbi
Jonathan Sacks
Benjamin Netanyahu Leon Kass I'm looking
over the list I was reminded that
Charles Krauthammer who was sadly you
know who died this summer was the second
awardee and really a wonderful talk
worth rereading they did that he gave my
mother who was slightly indisposed she's
in she's in good shape but couldn't
couldn't be here tonight since your best
to so many old friends and former
colleagues she congratulate s' Boris she
was pleased so she told me it's good
that they're giving the award to a
magazine editor and I said I mean my
mother you know his read probably read
bosses she said to me I read the London
I read The Spectator before Boris
Johnson was
born back in the 40s and 50s and read it
under his editorship and the I guess
Layton IDs early part of the 2000s and
has read it since and but I said you
know my me Boris became Mayor of London
for two terms I think it was and then
Foreign Secretary is he's not just a
magazine editor really and my mother
said for the for the crystals magazine
editor is the highest title which I of
course certainly agree with I really
just want to say a word but not about my
father at this time but about Arthur and
Arthur didn't know I was going to do
this but his ten years really have been
extraordinary here at AEI he followed
custom youth whose I think it was
twenty-two years were also extraordinary
and the lesson I take the deep instant
math lesson I take in management and
institutions from the tenure of Chris
and Arthur is that it's really a good
thing for an institution to have
excellent leaders yeah I recommend it to
everyone else here who's who's running
institutions I mean it really is that
it's a high standard obviously I think
of that a third of a century under Chris
and Arthur being the preeminent
think-tank I think in Washington and the
country perhaps in the world a place
that really respects excellence but also
respects diversity of views and
approaches that really shows that
excellence that diversity can go
together a place that has always
resisted I think looks fashionable tried
to look beyond the headlines while also
influencing the headlines at times tried
to follow intellectual conclusions to
their end and not worry too much about
whether they're popular at least in the
short term I mean all those things were
really an achievement of actually the
predecessors to christen Arthur but
especially of Chris and Arthur and
especially in this last decade of Arthur
he took over an institution that was
already strong and made it stronger yet
it's a very good example I think for us
in this day and age that shunning
vulgarity resisting conformity avoiding
mere popularity
is the right thing to do it's very much
in been in the long-term interest of a
which stands as an example now I think
not just other think tanks but actually
to the academic world Arthur's stepping
down as you know as president of AEI and
is also stepping down by going to
Harvard I hope I mean I say this I
shouldn't I say this is a loyal Harvard
man and but it's a true fact honestly
that the intellectual the caliber of the
work and the commitment to truth the
commitment to honest and respectful
discourse but also serious discourse in
terms of calling people to account is I
think something that Arthur can drink to
Harvard from a I or good luck with a
dart there but I do want to say that I
really think AI is an example not just
for DC and but for for the country and
indeed for the world with an example we
need more than ever maybe I could even
ask you I don't have a glass here but to
raise the glass and join me in toasting
Arthur Brooks said is what will be I
suppose the last annual dinner he'll
preside over he will of course it'll be
a huge number I'm sure of events before
he leaves in the spring and summer
Arthur's planning a whole bunch of them
annually convert commemorating his
tenure but since this is the last annual
dinner he'll be act let's offer a toast
to to our friend and our leader Arthur
Brooks
thank you Bill and thank you to all of
you one of the great one of the many
great things about this job is being
able to meet the most interesting people
in the world and it's actually easy you
call him up and say would you like to
come to a e.i and they almost always say
yes it's incredible and tonight's Award
winner is one of those people somebody
I've always wanted to meet probably you
have always wanted to meet him - he is a
member of the British Parliament he was
the UK Secretary of State for Foreign
and Commonwealth affairs he was the
mayor of London he's a best-selling
author and renowned historian he's a
cult figure in the UK as a matter of
fact famous for everything from tackling
a German politician in a soccer match to
having a bicycle named after him to his
hair and I say that just because I'm
jealous most importantly this is a man
who loves liberty who values free
enterprise and who understands the role
that his country and our country play in
the future of the world ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of the entire AEI
community our scholars staff and
trustees it is my honor to officially
award the American Enterprise Institute
2018 Irving Kristol award to the
Honorable Boris Johnson
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you thank you
Miss Donna thank you come on sit down
and we will get to dinner
[Applause]
I'm Brianna hallo Boris
good evening often good evening how
wonderful to see you here how delighted
I was the I was under stress because you
had votes last night in the Parliament
and had to come this morning and we were
were watching your flight all the way
across the Atlantic
well wild horses wouldn't have would
have kept me away and I'm absolutely
thrilled to be here the American
Enterprise Institute I was you could
have knocked me down with a feather when
I got the news that you were gonna give
me the the Irving Kristol award and I
haven't been so surprised since I I was
25 and I got a letter from Monash
University Melbourne saying that I was
going to be a professor of European
thought I turned out in a case of miss
agent mistaken identity tonight but it
was it was it's this is a very very
important institution I followed the
work of AEI scholars and of people
associated with this body for many many
years and you have been incredibly
influential and drivers for for change
and for things I believe in and it's
it's great to be here tonight Thank You
Boris thank you for your generosity on
behalf of all of us I want to start
we're gonna talk about highfalutin
things this evening but I want to start
at the personal level something that a
lot of people here don't know about you
you were born in America I was in New
York where my parents were I wouldn't
want to be close to my mother at the
time as they say and I it was a very
expensive decision because it turned out
that the United States what you call it
the Inland Revenue hmm the Internal
Revenue Service
well well-acquainted to the people in
this room yeah yeah
well anyway in order to help you guys
out they pursued me for the for the tax
on the sale of my primary dwelling in in
London even though I hadn't lived in
America for forty five years which I
thought was excessive so so with great
reluctance and it was it was it was a
very emotional moment with great
reluctance I had to forswear that
citizenship like the man in the Bible
I went soaring he had great possessions
not great possessions in my case but
enough so you realize that this this
makes it impossible for you to be
elected president of the United States
yes tell me about your upbringing one of
the things that we have in common is
that both of our mothers were
professional painters I found that
interesting and so tell me about your
childhood tell me about your upbringing
a little bit well it's absolutely true
my mother my mother's is she's a painter
and and I've always wanted to paint very
badly myself and and did he do very very
badly but I I I you know it's I'd say
she's been an inspiration to me she's by
the way she's she's very much on the
Left and I don't want irrelevance of
that is but she is and that she I'm
thoroughly supportive of painters
everywhere it's good now it seems to get
to is that Boris has the painter vote
they and you were brought up in a mixed
household left and right what brought
you to your politics that you currently
have funnily enough I was pretty I was
pretty kind of middle-of-the-road until
University where I was the exposure to
other left-wing students bourgeois
fluent hypocritical left-wing students
oh that's kind whoo yeah and and they're
virulent hatred of Margaret Thatcher
about whom I had no really strong views
until then and they supported the miners
leader Arthur Scargill in his attempt to
bring down the democratically elected
government of the UK and I first felt
the stirrings of conservative sentiment
then fundamental idea contrary well I
suppose I was I suppose I was that's
that's a good insight yes I was right
here my right wing feelings what would
triggered to use the modern word by a
sense of outrage at their gluttonous
hypocrisy so why don't we call it that
in the United States the gluttonous
hypocrisy would that win elections in
America I I think you should give it
again so when when was your first
elective office I want something I was a
student I think my first elect I tried
to get elected in Wales in 1997 which
was the the year of the biggest
conservative route since 1906 and I
fought I fought cleared South and
included south full-back you know in a
big way and I didn't win there by then I
then got in in 2001 in in Henley and
you've been in public life ever since
almost yeah I was I've heard that the
now one of the things that you're really
well known for besides public life
besides political life is being a
best-selling author which is pretty
unusual I mean it's particularly if it's
a highbrow intellectual work which
you're Churchill factor most certainly
is Churchill is somebody you admire a
great deal
in that great book which I recommend all
of you to your and for your interest is
Boris writes Churchill matters today
because he saved our civilization and
the important point is that only he
could have done it tell me a little bit
about your admiration for Winston
Churchill and the key lessons that you
learned from him today that we can all
learn for him today well the key thing
about Churchill was it he was so
fantastically brave you know this he
wasn't a big guy and he was he was
bullied at school he was pelted with
cricket balls and he ran away he was
only five foot six and a half inches
tall and he had a thirty inch chest as a
young man he was already he was a runty
shrimpy kind of guy you didn't know that
but he turned himself by sheer effort of
will into this extraordinary Colossus
who dominated so much of British
politics and world politics in the 20th
century and the key point for me is that
although he made so many mistakes and
got so many things wrong from Gallipoli
to the abdication crisis to going back
on gold to his attitude towards Indian
independence he's got things
catastrophic Iran but the one big thing
he got right in May 1940 when the UK had
to make a decision about whether to
fight on or to do a deal with Mussolini
and with Hitler and if Churchill hadn't
been in that room there's no doubt at
all in my mind that we would have come
to terms of some kind and he made all
the difference
because he basically decided that it
would be a disaster for his country for
the British Empire and for civilization
if we did that deal and within a year of
that decision 30,000 British men women
and children have been killed by Nazi
bombers
thirty thousand
but as a result of his decision to fight
on I believe that he saved the European
continent from absolute barbarism and so
it was it was it was a willingness now
just look at this it was it was a
willingness to think for himself and to
be brave that we need to we need to we
need to follow that today give me an
example give me an example of something
where we need to be brave to follow our
instincts to more noble ends well since
you since you dragged it from me kicking
and screaming as you didn't but I'll
tell you anyway I I think that we need
when it when you look at at our country
when you look at the the UK we have a we
have a great choice right now and we are
in the throes of some of you may have
seen from the news we're in the throes
of deciding exactly how to to carry out
this brexit we did quite well we got
through almost 10 minutes without breaks
it that's well it's all it's all over
now but we have a choice and I would
just say to all you scholars and
supporters of the American Enterprise
Institute this is a critical moment for
everybody who cares about free markets
about competition about global free
trade about all the things as you were
saying earlier on are for all things are
related billions of people out of
poverty the UK could be about to come
loose of the European system of
regulation and government it could be
about to enter the global system as an
independent economic actor again able to
campaign for pro-competitive policies
that's that's the opportunity and I hope
very much that with you with you guys
with America we can work together to
deliver that agenda and you know there's
a conversation going on in my country
about exactly how to do it it is
difficult but the last thing we want now
is for us
the Brits having made this momentous
decision to go for Bret seem to be
sucked back by the tractor beam of
Brussels the tractor beam is the word I
want into them into the orbit the the
regulatory lunar pool the Death Star
my daughter was born in Brussels so she
ran Zirin process I love Brussels a
wonderful time it's a wonderful time and
I love Belgium but the fact is that the
ear chocolate yeah yeah bureaucracy the
EU for all its achievements and there
have been great achievements so over the
last 50 60 years 70 years of the of the
EU's existence for all its achievements
it really is no longer right in its
current form for the UK we've done the
right thing we've done the right thing
but having done that having done that
we've got to make sense of it and there
is no point at all in us coming out of
the EU only two remain effectively in
large measure run by the EU if you're
going to take back control then take
back control and use it for a purpose so
I hope very much it will get the support
of of you guys in achieving that
objective I'm gonna I'm gonna come back
to this issue in just a minute but I
want to go slightly backward be to
another book that you wrote that bears
on this subject he wrote a very popular
book about the history of Rome an issue
on which a subject on which you have
some expertise and in it you observed
that one of the great things that the
Romans did was to create a common
identity across cultures and languages
and tribes and yet you have also
that you believe that Rome and the
European Union bear relatively little
resemblance so tell me tell me why
they're so different such that we can
get back to brexit and your
understanding of your separate or
separation from the EU and yeah how
that's in your interest yeah I was
living in in Brussels actually and
thinking deeply as I always do about the
European civilization and its
relationship with its with its past and
I have no doubt at all but in in a
deep-fried Ian's way the European
integration is the Federalists want to
recreate that idea of this great unified
whole that was represented by the Roman
Empire that that's at the core you look
at what some of the Mario Party said the
same thing just just the other day and
it was an amazing thing the Roman Empire
it lasted well from 7:30 to bc2 were
whatever you dated to you know some sage
so hasn't fallen you know 476 ad I
suppose you'd say was Roman Ursu it was
a long time it was fantastically
successful and I think the difference is
between the EU and the Roman Empire are
very instructive because what you've got
now is an attempt to create this unity
in this whole with a flag and with
anthems and and a sort of political
union and then I was talking about
creating a European president and that
and that kind of thing but what it lacks
is that Fingal charismatic sense of
identity and Allegiance that the Roman
Empire had everybody knew the Emperor
and everybody actually everybody
important around the Roman Empire had to
swear loyalty to the Emperor and in some
cases actually worship the Emperor and
the only real comparator with the Roman
Empire today in terms of that that
pungent sense of identity a pluribus
unum you know where I'm going with this
idea takes me is the United States
which which takes people from around the
world and makes them American and and
has this extraordinary global brand to
which everybody aspires and with the
best will in the world the EU isn't like
that the EU is composed of of different
proud countries that have their own
traditions and their own sense of
identity and yes I think there is
growing a kind of sense of European
identity but it's it's nothing by
comparison with the strength of national
feeling in the European continent and so
I think that the erosion of democracy in
the EU is worrying and you'll seeing
some bad effects now so give us some
advice here you're we're American you're
an admirer of the United States who I
know you love this country what do you
see in identity politics in America
today that reminds you a little bit too
much of the sub-national identities that
have made the EU project impossible to
achieve it's it's its own claims and due
to its own internal contradictions what
are the warning signs you see in America
today you know III think it'd be
important to me to to comment on
American politics all I will say is I
think that there is a I went to school
here other members of my family went to
school here there's a hey you have a
thing you pledge allegiance to the flag
we just everybody just sang the
star-spangled banner it's a
fantastically unifying culture and I
applaud that and I admire that I have to
say I think it's very important as for
the identity politics you know that's a
problem everywhere and we need to we
need to we need to be unifying well I
appreciate the fact that you you admire
that I I pray we never lose it I have no
I see no reason why you should now back
to brexit know you have strong views
obviously well-known strong news on
brexit a lot
of your fellow citizens in the UK
disagree with you on this you are a
national leader you people look to you
for leadership going forward in your
country
who knows what the future might bring
what are your plans for bringing America
back together as a people across the
terrible fissure that is differences on
brexit well as I say I think America is
in good shape I'm not going to comment
on about it I think I'm being pending me
to worry about America or even you know
if I were to recover my American
passport I might you know take a role
but the in the UK what we need to do is
get on and deliver a great brexit and I
have my views about how that should be
done I think it's possible to to do that
I think that a vision was sketched out
at the Lancaster House in in in January
of last year that a big free trade deal
and so on so we need to get that done
then we need to bring people together I
think people will want to come together
the best thing possible
to unify our country would be if we
could if we could have beaten the French
in the World Cup and that would that
really that would have been that was my
plan
but you know we're back to the drawing
board that we came forth we came second
in the Olympics by the way yeah yeah
yeah to you it wasn't bad you were
you're modest and you're in your advice
to the United States but I want to talk
a little bit about the United States in
your view a little bit morning I want to
talk about the special relationship with
the UK we talk about it a lot we it it's
an important to us and inspires all of
us and I know it's important to to you
and in the United Kingdom as well tell
me what does the special relationship
mean in your view where is it and and
what are the perils that we face today
well I banned the phrase special
relationship in the Foreign Office but
but because you know it sounds kind of
needy I'm not I'm not sure that it's
much used in in Washington I know it's
it's a phrase that was coined by I
suppose Churchill it was it was it's
part of its seats part of us trying to
be more special to you perhaps the
asymmetry was an asymmetry and as in so
many romantic relationships as an
asymmetry imply and that's why I reject
that term but it matters it matters
hugely we two countries do represent I
think values that are fantastic
importance to our world freedom
democracy the rule of law this stuff
really really matters and those values
are not uncontested right now and
they're not necessarily prevailing in
the way that we thought they were going
to and we need to work harder together
and that's why the special relationship
I use the praise but the UK and the u.s.
working together with our friends and
partners is more vital than ever for but
you know this is these are two countries
that are united by
economic salute I think we have a
million people go to work in the UK who
are in the US companies a million people
here in the States in in British
companies it's a it's an extraordinary
extremely thing and I guess I'm told you
watch the Great British Bake Off is that
right there you go I mean that is that
the most enthusiastic response I've had
leavening for I did I don't even watch
the Great British Bake Off myself I'm a
crime I'm ashamed I'm ashamed to say but
you know there is a huge cultural all
the journalists in New York seemed to be
Brits it's true I know what's what's
going on that's an exaggeration but you
know Brits everywhere yeah that's a
that's a fine thing so we can't say
special relationship anymore I'm trying
to think what would be more modern and
then thinking friends with benefits yeah
I don't know yet means something
different here sorry benefits you've
been very influential in finding ways to
performing benefits but policy here
that's really the best what do you
believe are the the given the fact that
there's there that there is a a
relationship special otherwise between
the UK in the United States what are the
top foreign policy priorities do you
think that we should be pursuing
together this is something you thought a
lot about this foreign secretary I did
well I mean you know we work hand in
blood across the across the world and
get back to my main point tonight I
think trade free trade opening up the
global economy I worry about I worry
about the closing in of our approach at
the moment global free global trade is
not growing in anything like the way it
should be we haven't had a big trade
deal since the end of the of the uruguay
round in 1994 I think which I covered
myself was as a journalist that we need
we need to be doing that together we
should be Saudi we should be we should
be doing better in we should be doing
better in in the Middle East
we should be working harder on was that
Syria I gotta be honest we think Syria
was our policy in retrospect was not the
right one but I don't to get and get on
that particular that particular rabbit
hole one thing we should do and I this
the biggest insight I had as Foreign
Secretary is that the main problems of
the world could be addressed if we if we
solved female under education around the
world if we educated women I when I went
to sub-saharan Africa or I went to South
Asia I would find countries where female
illiteracy was running at 50 60
sometimes 80 percent in parts of Africa
in Pakistan you have twice as many male
kids in secondary schools as female kids
now how can that produce a healthy
balanced approach to life I just I just
I felt in you you look at radicalization
you look at poverty in but all the the
scourge is that we we face they're all
associated with that band of countries
where women are not treated equally
where women and girls are not treated
even so the one thing and it's a kind of
do you have a Swiss Army knife yes do
you know I don't mean by a Swiss Army
knife
it has it can kind of do anything I
think female education 12 years of
quality education for every girl in the
world would help to fix most of the
problems in the world and we should do
that
I really do you you have very strong
views about the future of your country
as is appropriate and a lot of people
follow what you think a lot of people
admire your leadership here and in your
own country obviously your role in the
leadership of the UK could change a lot
in the coming months and years you must
have given this some thought I'm sure
you have tell me the two things you'd
most like to see your government do in
the coming years social mobility social
mobility that was you know you think
back to the great achievements of the
Thatcher era I spoke of earlier it was
about helping people to seize control of
their own destiny whether it was owning
shares which they hadn't thought of
doing before or buying their own homes
fantastically important and since that
big change in the 1980s social mobility
is frozen again and we need to recover
that we need to recover that momentum in
the in the UK and you wanted two things
I think well I think build a 24-hour hub
airport not in my constituency number
one for you your Tom agenda item for
your country is greater social mobility
yeah no question I mean one of the
reasons bricks it took place oh one of
the reasons people voted to leave it was
because they felt they weren't getting a
fair suck of the source bottle as they
say that they were being stunned people
are stuck in entry-level jobs they're
not progressing and we're not focusing
on those issues we're not helping people
enough I think we discussed this area
with them where they're not being made
to feel needed needed and it's a serious
problem and I think it perhaps affects
this country too before we finish I have
one question I really always wanted to
ask you about your in your public life
you you're in the news a lot
sometimes you see controversy you're not
afraid to take on
hottest issues of the day tell me the
biggest mistake you've made in your
public career and what you learn from it
well my strategy is to litter my career
with so many decoy mistakes nobody knows
which one to attack I don't know what in
the course of the last few minutes I
probably sent something that the British
media will decide is absolutely
outrageous I don't know what it was but
they will find something believe me then
the Athenians to keep saying them I was
very proud of a lot of the stuff I did
in London you know and people attacked
me for the cycle superhighways for
instance which are beautiful lanes for
the for the for the bicycles which
unfortunately block the taxis and they
get they get very cross but I defend it
we save lives of cyclists and I think
it's a beautiful thing to do for a city
I'm a totally passionate cyclist so I
didn't come out and say the biggest
mayor I seriously seriously by the way
bicycles in London are called Boris
bikes they're good home Boris taxis
never returned we have them not -
there's the electric vehicles we started
them at we saw them anyway or must be
London's getting great come and visit
exactly well it wasn't in the new guy
anyway never mind I did make a big guy
give you one mistake and it relates to
the news today and how we doing wrap up
in this point yeah
when I became foreign secretary I
decided I mean I thought there was no
objective reason why we should be quite
so hostile to Russia okay I thought that
I mean yes there were lots of reasons to
be suspicious lots of reasons to be
aware II lots of reasons to be very very
cautious but I thought it was possible
I made the classic
classic mistake of thinking it was
possible to have a reset with Russia and
I wanted to engage with Putin and with
Sergei Lavrov and to see if we could
start talking about things Aaron like
Syria areas where we had where we needed
to engage where we needed to do things
together
tackling Islamist terrorism and so on
and then it just became clearer and
clearer to me that that was a fool's
errand and finally on March the 4th I
think it was this year we had this
outrageous event in Salisbury in
Wiltshire where two agents of the
Russian GRU were involved in a the
murder the murder of dawn sturgis and
the attempted murder of others and you
know you see that you see what's
happening now with these two characters
produced in this satirical way by Putin
on Russian TV asks these ludicrous Patsy
questions making a mockery of the whole
thing and it really makes my blood boil
and you know I I just think
because for a government for a
government that wants to be taken
seriously to behave like that in 2018 we
really have to treat them with I mean I
hope I hope that regime in absolute
absolute content I think it's absolutely
appalling and you know I say I'll say
now I think the I think that the you
know and I say to them - those two guys
who are on on TV on Russian TV yeah they
are murderers and if it and if they
dispute that fact then they can sue me
in the in the in the in the courts and I
think you news for us
I mean you you you said the biggest
mistake you've made in your public
career is having trusted the Russians
I wasn't that I trusted them I believed
I was sufficiently I was sufficiently
overconfident to think that I could I
could reach out and engage and actually
make a difference and they wouldn't and
they just haven't changed but I'll say
so I'll say one thing just just in
conclusion we've could take on the
special ratio problem with no lie you
know I did myself to use that phrase on
the relationship knee the US and the UK
what was so fantastic was that after the
use of knowledge shock in Salisbury 28
countries around the world came together
and there are more to come by the way
came together and expelled the biggest
number of Russian spies collectively
that we've ever seen and I just want to
pay a tribute to the United States
because you guys I'm not certain how
universally popular it was at that
decision at every level of government
but by gum you came through with the
goods you did you you expelled 60
Russian spies and I want to say on
behalf of the British people we are
really really grateful for the
Solidarity
the new show and you know thank you very
much and if that by the way if that is a
special relationship that I
I'm I'll take it we'll take it all day
long
where we're at the end of our time Boris
on behalf of my colleagues and friends
and and personally I want to express my
admiration for a lot of things that
you've done but in particular for the
attitude the public attitude you've had
of optimism toward all the people in
your society all the people who need
more mobility all the people who are at
the periphery of society who might
suffer from despair but can hear your
words and can to hear the words of
leaders and understand that an
opportunity society can and should be
available to every person in your
country and indeed that is the
inspiration behind our institution that
an opportunity society should be open to
everyone for that witness for that
mission on behalf of all of us please
join me in thanking Boris Johnson thank
you
[Applause]